[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui sauve de la cheminée la
fumée
il y a plusieurs siècles dans un château
d'Italie à travers une cheminée par vin
des voies qui semblent préparer un
complot contre une personnalité
importante
on décida alors pour mieux entendre les
compléteurs de faire nettoyer la
cheminée et bien entendu le complot
échoua depuis quand on parle de ramoneur
on pense encore au petit savoyard qui
coiffait de son traditionnel bonnet de
laine se promener à travers la France de
toi en toi et nettoyer les cheminées
pour quelques sous il peut arriver
qu'une cheminée soit bouchée que des
oiseaux y a fait leur nid la fumée ne
peut alors s’échapper normalement et il
y a des risques graves d'incendie et
d'asphyxie
pourquoi il est toujours obligatoire de
procéder une fois par an au ramonage des
cheminées
le métier de ramoneur dangereux et
difficile tant de plus en plus à
disparaître à cause des techniques
modernes de chauffage et de construction
reste quand même quelques hommes qui
continuent d'aimer se promener sur les
toits de Paris
de ramonage et j'appelle mon compagnon
en bas pour repérer le bon conduit et là
j'entends pour savoir donc je continue
[Musique]
voilà ça c'est une corde de ramoni du
vrai sudiste avec sa boule et son
hérisson la boule s'est entraîner
l'hérisson qui va rentrer dans donc dans
un conduit qui va gratter les parois des
conduits pour ramener et enlever les
mauvaisesuis
[Musique]
loulou il y a quelque chose qui accroche
compense un coup la corde ça passe pas
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui sort de la cheminée dans
la femelle non le Père Noël
[Musique]